what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today as of this
moment of filming this i am still
quarantining even though i'm feeling so
much better i did take a rapid yep
definitely still got the vid diesel with
that be catching up on some movies here
i feel like that's just a great way to
to make the most of it and i just want
to say really fast i've really been
enjoying doing you know like these movie
reaction reviews catching up on films
i've never seen before leave some
recommendations down in the comments
below uh i just really like the format
of this you know it's like it's not too
much different than doing a show but you
know to be able to do like an instant
spoiler review and then share my
experience of watching a movie that many
of you have already seen it's just so
fun and enjoyable so thank you for for
being here and since a lot of this has
been catch up based off recommendations
that you guys have been throwing my way
um i figured why not mix it up a little
bit i haven't done a horror movie in a
while so let's watch the movie sinister
today don't anything about it don't know
any details other than ethan hawk is in
this scott derricks and directed film
but in terms of plot no nothing i have
actually a big affinity for horror and i
know this is actually
quite quite a blood film i think beloved
i'm not sure people like it oh yeah
leave a like that also be great and
subscribe to become a citizen of the
reject nation and fooling through
reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with your own copy for sinister or over
at our patreon page for super sexy
rejects cover a whole bunch of stuff
over there some exclusive content as
well lastly the team of prepper thank
you for helping me edit down these
highlights you guys have been an
absolute blessing as of late so
let's get to it guys
[Music]
that's an opening shot
oh that's freaking eerie
oh man
opening image established tone mood good
we are a messed up movie no i had to
move here the new story i'm writing is
here
i miss my school
all right you know what
the school here is supposed to be pretty
great but i want my old one if we don't
like it here once i sell my book we'll
move back but only if we don't like it
here
what the [ __ ] is she drawing we didn't
move in a few houses down from a crime
scene again did we
tracy no just don't say anything i if we
did i don't want to know about it did
you guys move into a crime scene
promise
i promise oh my god you moved into a
murder house
oh
it's the tree where the people were
hanging
you gotta be kidding me
family hanging out 11.
oh that's in poor taste that's important
unless there's actually family hanging
out
yes i'm listening let's at least make
sure your office stays locked it's one
thing to hear about it it's another
thing to see it i don't want him walking
in again he's 12 years old mom he knows
how old i am hey stop it i forgot how
old you were
always lock dad's office that's right
and i don't want to hear another thing
about why we're here from anybody yeah i
predict someone will go into dad's
office and it will be unlocked
if this goes sour like last time
i'll take trevor and ashley and go back
home to my sisters
but it's not going to go sour
good kicks in love
all right show a little bit of like
positive reinforcement now
ethan hawk just seems like one of the
coolest dudes
wow you figured out fast i'd be spending
like an hour and a half
[Music]
did people back then find eight
millimeter footage creepy too
[Music]
oh [ __ ] see it is hanging out with the
family
wait
so that's
seems like such a
dumbass that's a family
[Laughter]
oh god i hope this doesn't become like a
shining thing where his family ends up
there
that is a good question
did i miss a line about them not getting
electricity in this home
daddy i can't find the bathroom
look at all these new paintings you're
really getting good maybe one day i'll
paint something really good then i'll be
famous like you you don't want to be
famous the way he's famous
[Music]
how crazy would it be if ethan hawk was
playing that guy too
what the [ __ ] these are like
a whole bunch of snuff videos
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
you know in some ways he really stumbled
onto a gold mine here
king county police department how may i
direct your call
king county police department how may
direct your call
hello
oh
damn it
you had an opportunity to make a right
choice
but you want that 15 minutes of fame
hawk
ashley
that is very noticeable
whoa it's his son
what the hell
[Applause]
oh my god
hey wake up come on come on come on wake
up yeah that was a hell of a frantic
shot
why are we outside all right okay
we're having a bad dream okay one of
those night terrors
it's just the stress of the move i found
them in one of the one of the moving
boxes
what a very specific way to have night
terrors i'm just really sorry
it's not your fault
come on it's cold that's good
for some reason i really felt that
apology
[Music]
oh man dude call the cops
this person left the box there
how icky
[Music]
i got some [ __ ] up videotapes
weird
oh
man that's unfortunate
[Music]
man and he can't you can't just like
talk to his wife about this [ __ ] either
your son is acting out again all right
what did he do oh so you're
automatically taking herself stop it
what did you do
i drew a picture he drew a picture with
a permanent marker on the classroom
whiteboard tell him what you do
i drew a tree with four people hanging
from it oh
no
nothing about what happened to these
people is okay but bad things happen to
good people and they still need to have
their story told they deserve that much
you're a real man of the people
[Laughter]
trying to spin it like he's trying to do
a good deed
[Music]
it's like this whole movie's just him
watching an anthology of super 8 films
[Music]
don't kill the dog
[Music]
[Applause]
dude i don't think you're cut out for
this job he seems way too affected by
everything
[Music]
uh oh
jack torrance on our hands
i gotta say i really like ethan hawk's
performance in this so far there's
actually quite a lot of layers to his
character already
what what does it say
police have released this photo of
christopher miller the missing
13-year-old son of william and penny
miller the millers along with their
younger son were found stabbed inside
their home you get the [ __ ] out of this
house man
serial killer watcher
he's being watched
again the electricity in this house
dude i'd be so paranoid
[Laughter]
getting anxiety enough as it is
was this movie shot on film it kind of
looks that way
you are a brave brave soul man
i actually really liked it how extreme
or that
what
that is
like some devil [ __ ]
family hanging out pool party
sleepy time
don't just leave that here man
take it with you
yikes
well the bleeding stopped for now but if
it starts again or there's any more
swelling i want you to call a doctor
immediately thank you appreciate it
i've noticed he has never left this
house
i'm guessing that you got squirrels i
bet that they got spooked from the sound
of everything shutting down at once
you know they are not really
i'm not really a squirrel guy
oh
i am
i did kill a scorpion when we first
moved in here though so maybe i should
get an exterminator scorpions have feet
but you wouldn't hear him like you would
[Laughter]
1998 st louis a family was stabbed to
death actually they had their throats
cut in 1979 a family was burned alive
parked inside their own car in their own
garage
what city
i don't know all i have is a year in the
method of execution
this guy's like deputy dewey
so ultimately what feels better
seeing justice done or seeing your your
book kentucky blood number one on the
new york times bestseller list the
justice
and without question is that the truth
[Music]
good catch oh looks like an alien
[Music]
at least the clues are just being laid
out for you crystal clear so we have to
make it just right
he's very particular about his coffee
i'm really capturing the way this
coffee's made
2976 piedmont way st louis that is
excellent two nines wait did you say two
nine seven six like 29.76 yeah why does
that mean something to you uh no no it
doesn't no thank you thank you deputy
just keep looking at that image we
inverted moves moved here they lived
where the miller family murders happened
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
good old spooky fun spooky fun
holy moly that is creepy
[Music]
the gifts are coming for you
don't just brush that off i would get a
second eye on that make sure
like you see what i'm saying
oh god you need a therapist keep
wondering if he's like already dead and
he's in some weird purgatory
are you slowly giving life to this thing
yikesy
oh
i found him outside we have to put a
buck in his door it's way worse than it
was i'll call the doctor in the
morning i used to stay with him i left
something outside
well that is just spooky as
don't want to hurt [ __ ]
i just want to get
my bad
drop the book
we can pack up get out of town and never
look back you know why because he's
having some night terrors more than that
he's never been this bad you've never
been this bad you're talking about less
than a week and you're already a mess
it's been less than a week oh my god
i'm on her side now this could be my in
cold blood uh a movie deal uh talk show
circuit right the national book award
and more money than we could you know we
could live i don't care about any of
those everybody doesn't lose this is my
shot tracy
your sin is greed
if you want me to run interference for
you while you get this worked out i got
to be in the loop
just a little bit you really want to
help
it's my home it's rothful what happened
here happened to all of us
they both got that like uh conflicting
shadow thing i don't know it's just like
being consumed by the darkness you think
these are serial murders maybe more
ritualized than necessarily serial but
really spread out and not just
regionally but over time the first one i
found dates back to the 60s
the 1960s
in each instance the killer murdered the
entire family except one a child which
he took with him you might want to call
the university there's a professor over
there professor jonas he's an occult
crime expert and the state police bring
him in on some of the app
the weirder stuff i don't want that cop
to die he seems so sweet
i like the
the plays of shutter speed it's like you
have a
different kind of camera use for the
transitions into a different camera lens
you're about to see a pov through it's
pretty cool
so where's this little girl now
if you find yourself trying to figure
out the mystery dude
it's the goddamn devil
[Music]
he murdered the lawnmower
that
was just a combination of all sentences
that are there that's actually i really
like that jump scare because it's so
hypnotic with the music and the visuals
it was getting like entranced in it then
it felt like my chest just tied in so
much there
thank you for getting back to me so
quickly i appreciate that uh of course
i'm a a really big fan i'm flattered
that you thank you once i saw the photos
that you said i knew exactly what cases
that you were studying wait how kingpin
are their hero it's a symbol
associated with the worship of a pagan
deity a deity what kind of deity
a a very obscure one dating back to
babylonian times named bagool the eater
of children
did you say eater
he looks so frightened
each story
involves a a different way that he lures
or tricks these children
away from the physical world and
of course the few times that this symbol
has
shown up none of the crimes have been
related in any way to any of this and so
this might be more of a cult initiation
rather than you know the actual actions
of any one man sure that's better
what the [ __ ]
dude move
[ __ ]
[Music]
i like the way the little girl ghost
plays
creepy
i'm assuming they're the kids that were
hung
all right let's have some specific
markings
so i'd say you can hear
it's an interesting choice let you see
the ghosts
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god
no
no no no no no
that poor girl
i am not a fan of that
uh
i'm an offender it's good it's good
scary [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's like the first time we really
broke perspective from ethan hawk
these are more fun to watch with you
guys than just me by myself
so i appreciate you coming by officer oh
yes it's
not a problem at all
so we're we're becoming friends right i
mean i suppose yeah
i mean i can trust you right yeah
absolutely lose my [ __ ] mind
okay well does your wife know about it
does she know
whose house this is
was
oh man
oh that is a conversation that i would
not want to be around
here here there was none of that uh
with the stevenson son
no in the shortest amount of time that
the stevenson's lived here they never
called the police they never had the
police called on them or reported
anything bizarre that came up in the
investigation
you know i was so good at this i like
this cop a lot too there's a whiskey
bottle in your office that doesn't
appear to be the slightest neglected mrs
all right mr oswald miss roswell listen
i don't i don't i'm not saying that you
have a drinking problem okay i don't
think that nor do i think that you're
making any of this up no to get
attention i don't think that
[Laughter]
this is such a good scene work
i thought
something was in the house
and i woke up on the couch holding a
baseball bat
if you sleep in this house it's just
gonna do terrible things to your head
yeah man you don't need to be here
you have a second house you can move
back to paint only goes in the bedroom
what makes you think you can paint out
here
i wanted to paint her picture but she
didn't want it in my room because that
used to be her brother's room what
she's the one daddy's writing his book
about
actually go to your room and shut the
door that conversation's about to happen
i really do think it's cool they let you
see that the little girl did experience
the ghost like they actually showed you
that we never should have come here
nobody died here okay it's not like
we're sleeping where somebody was killed
it's not like they had to wipe blood off
the walls for the opening
it didn't happen here no
it happened in the backyard
i think that makes a difference
no ellison it doesn't
the kind of jeopardy you put your
children in your marriage yes i do i
understand what you won't do for your
goddamn book
i guess this is all worth it to you
what's worth it putting your family at
risk what risk of what of more paintings
don't oh my god mr minimizer man there
are plenty of other ways you can provide
for this fight during what don't you
understand
that writing is what gives my life
meaning
these books are are my legacy
man this is such a cautionary tale
you and me right here this marriage
that's the meaning of your life
and your legacy
that's ashley and trevor
your kids are your legacy
this is true
what the [ __ ]
no
he's starting to be recorded
[Music]
all right it's eight millimeter footage
of the ladder
so you can see all this
right you can see the kids
see like
the wife would have heard all that right
like the clashing on the ground
i made a mistake we should have never
come to this house
we have to leave now
oh you're freaking me out here get the
kids pack the car we have to leave are
they gonna be able to leave
[Music]
hey he's out of the house there goes all
my theories where are we going daddy
we're going home honey
[Music]
oh great
[Music]
they did talk about getting pulled over
at the beginning of this movie i don't
want to be reading in your book that
angry town folks chased you out of here
there isn't going to be any bug
just one more favor
hold it under 60 till you cross the
county line
and do you somebody else's problem
i ain't fun for any of this [ __ ]
no
the terror has followed they used to
live there
now they live here
right isn't that the trajectory of like
they used to live there
maybe people did i don't know i don't i
can't figure this out
it's like what is it what's the goddamn
reveal bagola actually
lived in the images themselves and that
they were gateways into his realm
the ancient church believed that he
would take possession of those who saw
the images and caused them to do
terrible things your call came so late
answer
man to hell with addicts
oh my god
[Music]
extended cut endings
oh man that is mean
call the cop back that cop has some
answer for you man
the dates the addresses each family that
you had me look up had previously lived
in the house where one of the earlier
murders took place
exactly but before the miller family was
killed the millers lived in the same
house in orange county where the
delusional lawn massacre kurt if this
guy is still out there you not only just
sped up his timeline you put yourself in
it
it's like they
shoves you out of the house
and that's the final step
oh my god
put this on your cell phone that is
creepy as hell
stephanie
[Music]
oh they gotta compile it all to one
your daughter or your son could be
either one of them you gotta kill them
both
no no
holy [ __ ] don't worry daddy i'll make
you famous again
it's oh some tails from the [ __ ] kind of
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god
it's crazy the little girl on the poster
[Music]
oh that's terrible man
[Music]
huh
[Music]
she just jumps in the frame
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it was like uh tales from the crypt
[Music]
nice one
not bad i enjoyed the hell out of that
one
i heard the sequel's not as good
what is it just like lore exploration
was great that was great
gotta got some thoughts that i
definitely want to dive into and just
wait to see if there's a post credit
scene okay ladies and gentlemen i am not
going to [ __ ] you
uh
in between stopping the movie i went to
go to the bathroom
i was like a kid again
i went to the bathroom and then
the second i stepped out of this door
it's just this pitch-black hallway it's
like it's it's 3 26 a.m right now this
is this pitch black hallway and i could
see into another room and it was pitch
black
and i was legit scared i i kept thinking
i was gonna see mr buggy
and then i went to the bathroom and the
window was open and i was like oh god
damn
it's happening to me
great
great
that means it's effective
it's uh yeah you know i i liked it i
liked it a lot i thought i think there's
a lot of great qualities about this film
i like that it has this like cool blend
of
true crime
with this undercurrent of like a
percolating supernatural horror as well
it's got this really cool mix of both
you know and as someone who is
is very much interested in both of those
genres and uh very a fan i would say
it was cool to see a story that really
blended both while also
hearkening to works of stephen king and
then also hearkening to you know like i
really liked uh the show tales from the
crypt which i i know i mentioned a
couple of times here but those are
always like cautionary tales
about
usual usually it's the downfall of
someone usually is the downfall of
someone doing something terrible and
then they get what's coming to them and
that's not exactly what this is
but it's still a cautionary tale of you
know
watching how this
like the twist the reveal of it this
bites them in the ass about
how oh he's he keeps saying he wants to
be provide for the family but he's so
he's so
you know motivated
by
but ultimately what is like a greedy
desire you know but it's it's a very
relatable desire that's that's what i
thought was really effective about it
because i think a lot of people will
often be in this situation like i
thought a lot of the arguments that were
written between
him and and the wife were
pretty realistic you know i like those
little moments where usually it can be
played out in a cliche way and at times
it felt like you know there was such
good rhythm to the back and forth of the
dialogue with some of these arguments
that that was the one thing that really
helped it really helped save it from
becoming like frustrating or perfunctory
you know like little lines that would be
thrown in there of like i'm uh you know
like yeah we gotta have all this money
it's gonna be my capote book you know
like then the name of the book too
reminds me of you know i think it's a
very intentional thing of playing on
capote's cold blood book um
but when they are fighting he's like
yeah do this for all this money it's
like we don't i don't care about the
money the wife says and then you know he
interjects yeah everyone does a little
bit i'm like yes that's that's that
feels more real to me as opposed to
having like a bunch of dramatic pauses
in between
i think the way the back and forth is
with a lot of the scene work was really
great and that helped really drive home
the points even more and actually paint
a a solid gray area
for a lot of this debate you know and
because i think fleshing out the ethan
hawk character whose name i'm totally
forgetting even though i just watched
this movie um i was going to call him
ethan hawk i think
the combination of the writing of ethan
hawk's character of how
that is what's propelling this journey
and then of course ethan hawke's
performance really bringing that to life
because you know he hops back and forth
between saying two things
which is
you know like oh i want to do
good i want to save this person i want
to do right i need to solve this crime
but then also
he's got the thing of blind ambition and
chasing those glory days the the al
bundy days as i usually refer to it and
you know chasing those glory days and
the times where he felt adored and was
wealthy you know living the american
dream and he can't just appreciate what
he has
in front of him you know there's like
another version of this movie where i
could see like a guillermo del toro
story where it would have a bit more of
a fairy tale ending where he does
ultimately learn the right thing and he
gets to live with his family and and and
and be happy after some glorious
supernatural um you know finale but that
obviously is not the case here that's
not the kind of horror movie this is but
with the ethan hawk character
what was
what was great about it was i believe
again that gray area i believe
both sides you can see that there are
shades of him that obviously really want
to solve this because of his obsession
with
solving the case in a time and you could
and you could see
how he's not just some cold-blooded guy
when watching the found footage
qualities uh watching all the things
that were left behind for him to to
dissect
he's very much affected and squeamish
and and horrified and
you know because it's also watching
families and like little kids being
killed
you could already pick up on the
performance without him having to say it
that if he's a father himself and of
course you know he could be flashing to
his own children as well
and i i really think ethan hawk provided
both of those qualities because his
character is in conflict with himself
like while a lot of times he will lay
down that it it's like yeah about the
money it's about the money but no it's
actually about this
and you can see that there is that
conflict where they they are like
combating
with the with each other uh throughout
at least that's the way i interpreted it
that i thought
um there were times where he really just
did care about solving this and didn't
care to want to know the truth and
understanding and clearly because even
he at the end he was like i did
by the time he was back at the house
he didn't want to um
write a book anymore but he but he still
had to know he still had to know the
truth especially when scary ass spooky
[ __ ] just keeps happening and of course
he has to know the truth what the hell
would you when you box the show back up
in the attic and such uh so i thought
that ethan hawk absolutely killed it
like the the anguish in his performance
it was very
very human and very natural and he
didn't like overplay the drama you watch
this character really descend
over time like so much earlier on i
could already pick up on all these
different layers because there's such a
build up to everything sort of
collapsing on itself internally and
externally
with
with with ethan hawk's relationship with
as a dad and as a husband and that that
buildup of tension with him and his wife
because it was constantly
you know
like i don't like being here ethan
i don't like being here and
i i
you could do something else to provide
we don't need the money and all this
stuff
and then fighting and then oh i'm sorry
no i love you you know like it was it
was kind of this uh pattern that just
kept
building and building and building upon
itself till it was just starting to
really
implode upon implode upon the two of
them
and
i think that there was such great nuance
handled on things that could have
just been solely tropes uh because it's
in fact sometimes i felt like they would
do
certain horror motifs and tropes
in order to mislead you
and make you think something else is
about to happen
when
it doesn't and i thought that was there
was great usage of it and i actually
really like i know when you say jump
scares
there's this one pocket of the internet
of the world that like gawks at that
word but i think jump scares when
utilized properly can be quite effective
and make for an exciting
experience
and i thought the use of jump scares
here was also used very well and like
some of them were just truly like oh my
god that was really just
like some of the jump scares would like
just like
like land their claws into your soul and
just like
and i really appreciated that because
a lot of times you can see jump scares
coming and even at times you could see a
jump scare coming
it would be a different kind of
combination of sensory experiences
that
would still get me so jolted again it
was like kind of being like electrocuted
for a while just
i liked it i like i liked the way i
liked the way that was handled and i
think scott derrickson's direction here
is really cool
because you know you're you're this
character's picking up you know um
a super eight
has a projector
and
you're hopping between two different
cinematic styles which is the found
footage eight millimeter footage
very creepy stuff snuff film it very
creepy um
yeah that was
some creepy ass [ __ ]
but then you know once in a while i
would get a little pulled out like
something's like i don't actually know
what it looks like for someone to have
their throat slit like i don't i don't
actually know what that looks like
but it did still look like cinematic
cutting it looked like movie cutting
of someone's neck so it would still kind
of pull me out a little bit but that's
like my one nitpick about that level of
violence like i thought the the use of
the other ways of violence i thought
were way way creepier than having the
the knife of the throat
um
you know like tying them up on the pull
benches and then
drive on dragging them into the into the
water that was
super creepy that one really stands out
to me
uh
the the ones being like tied up in in
the car being on fire or
even like that really effective one with
the with the lawnmower how just cut away
right away
uh when it was about to like go over the
person's head
like that was
i like the way that was edited thank god
we didn't actually see that that was i
wouldn't i don't know why that's not fun
that's not fun at all
like this this movie managed to
deal with true crime deal with
supernatural horror while at the same
time being really entertaining and also
being dreadful like it had that cool
like that blumhouse flavor where it is
like a fun horror movie still
but also in that other
qual that other genre that is like
considered elevated horror where it's
very it's mainly psychological
uh more than it is you know wanting to
be
fun spooky horror that's about unpacking
all these these myths and lores
and you do get that like the the the
reveal
that's why i said it when i was reacting
to it that's why they cut to
because this whole movie's from ethan
hawk's perspective
and i always take note when you break
perspective i'm very i i tend to get
really caught up on
on in movies of how perspective is
captured and so when i had that one
moment
when it because it starts playing with
the audience
it's sorry i'm starting to get like a
bunch of thoughts that are starting to
like flow in right now um
it starts playing with the audience
where yeah oh that's cool that's
brilliant i just appreciated this movie
a lot more
because this movie deals so much with
imagery like you got the eight
millimeter camera
at the projector
then you got
the way the movie actually just looks
like an uh like a modern day film
and you know you're dealing with
laptops
you got a different bunch of images and
screens and then you do have that moment
when mr boogie does uh turn on in the
laptop and looks at ethan hawk
and
it does seem to have that there's like a
word for it what is that word
damn i can't count i can't come up with
a word but
the part of the philosophy of it
is
is like images
you get consumed enough with images they
start to
kind of like look back at you
if
yes i think we're making that up i think
that's a thing i've heard about um
and
and then eventually
you know it's like the movie itself in
its relationship with the audience
starts to look back at you as well
where it does start to kind of break the
veil and break perspective where
you start to see the creeks which are
actually the ghost children they
actually the movie starts to show you
the ghosts
and
when ethan hawk can't see the ghosts
and it and it was a neat way to play
with the horror motif of little kids
because it only enhanced the mystery
more like it had had my mind constantly
going
is ethan hawk already dead is he already
a ghost that's in the dial like i was
really like kind of jumping ahead and
thinking of other things because they
were messing with this trope but at the
same time it was pulling back that veil
so you know it's starting to clue the
audience in by
we're watching the image of the movie
and then the image now looking back at
us
with the oh that's so cool i actually
really like that i mean this could just
be my wild interpretation about it but i
feel like that's what the movie's doing
but the image is looking back at us
and you have uh like you see the ghost
children and then you break perspective
for the first time out of all the
characters to to then just slowly lock
onto
um the daughter and see that you're
interacting with the kid and giving like
some actual clues here as to
you're giving actual clues here and and
and looking back i'm like okay there are
because any part of a good twist reveal
is
i i like the feeling of going oh yeah i
could have put that together maybe
and because i did start to think like
maybe the little girl's grown up because
you know like the movie eventually lets
you in on
it's a supernatural horror they
eventually let you know this is a
supernatural horror film
and
because i never
i never got to the point where i'm like
is this
is this all in his head
is this this real
is it not real is it is it what what is
this you know it didn't actually have me
debate that and maybe the movie didn't
want you to but i feel like kind of
telling you early on like no there's
some real supernatural [ __ ] actually
happening here
and
and uh and i just lost my shirt because
i got so many thoughts coming in here
i i think the way the movie yeah because
it was messing with the audience and i
like the way
it it messes with the audience it starts
to become a bit of a
meta experience in that regard and the
way scott derrickson messes with the
different film styles and shutter speeds
and
messing with horror motifs to make you
question things
and uh you know being the the lighting
uh there's the eerie lighting
uh where so much of the time characters
are
entering from first being in darkness
and then they enter into light or they
walk into darkness or everything is very
dark this is a very dark movie it's like
shadow
eventually over consuming
everyone with
some grade a acting from ethan hawk
throughout and i think the the cop
deputy so and so i think do we ever
learn the cops name uh deputies so and
so uh such an earnest performance and i
thought it was gonna be like oh here we
go just the the dumb cop bunch of
comedic relief jokes and then they
evolved him into something more and you
do show that he is very capable and
actually smart like
you know it wasn't just uh the dummy got
a job in dumb town uh he actually
shows that oh okay it makes sense why
he's a cop like he he can actually do
his job when the time comes for it
um and also him being a reflection of
him being a cop himself but also kind of
wanted a little bit of that
that fame and recognition and that
obsession with true crime to a certain
extent i i i think the
the mirroring of that was was really
cool and i i really appreciated him part
of me wants to know if he's in sinister
too like apartment goes okay i i i'm not
i'm not itching to instantly watch
sinister 2 right away because i've i've
heard that it's not as good
and
uh uh but i'm like but if he's in it i
might want to check it out actually so
yeah uh
he was he was a great character
the some of my little qualms uh that i
would have with the movie though do come
down to as much as i appreciated the
more realistic
writing and and performance especially
uh i don't know the wife's that i don't
know the wife's character name or
the actors uh but
they're
like i thought the performance is over
most were really elevated i couldn't
tell if it was quite the writing or the
acting because
even though there is a pretty big
realism to the repetition and the
escalation of their relationship at
times uh she she would i would find her
a little frustrating
uh and in term
it just started feeling like a little
bit of like
trophy in the way she was ultimately
written i thought
adding in a little bit more of those
nuances of like oh yeah i've calmed down
i was taking something out of you i'm
sorry does help eliminate some of that
uh but there were certain moments where
i did find myself
being like a little frustrated but then
again he's the ultimate [ __ ] and it
makes sense why she would be
uh have that much tension built up in
her while they kept doing that i might
take that one back i might take that one
back you know in the immediacy of the
moment i would sometimes feel it but
thinking back on it doesn't really
bother me that much what i did really
crave
was and i know this is kind of common
with horror movies and kind of movies in
general where the main characters aren't
kids was a little bit more fleshing out
of the children uh i wouldn't have
minded an extra like
five ten minutes just to have the kids
feel like have real personalities you
know it's like the the kid boy was uh
was just
angsty teen or having night terrors
and it was kind of just those two notes
you know one very effective creepy note
and
the yeah i was just like exciting
creepy and it's kind of like such a
horror movie thing and then the little
girl was like
i'm a little girl you know not that no
not real personalities to them and and i
could i re especially with seeing
who the personalities are of these
parents and how involved they are with
their kids
i i did find myself going like uh i
would probably care just that much more
about even though i'm really emotionally
invested and i really care
uh about like the
about it's like i don't want the family
to die i just don't want them to die
i'm really invested in ethan hawk i i
did
go oh that would have just pushed this
movie up that much more if the kids were
ridden better and and i think it would
have made the
the the twist
that much more effective because it does
feel like horror movie kid at the end
you know it's a little it's a little
goofy which is like writing uh or
drawing it's a little goofy but it would
have made it that much more effective i
thought if if they if they have more
meat
to the writing of them another thing
that i want to credit to is the score
there was that great pulsating like
throbbing
uh electronic
way to it where at times it would just
sound like uh like just this shrill
sound effect
instead of
instrument
and i i think
i think that was really cool to kind of
have this like weird sensory meditative
experience with it where
at times you couldn't tell if it was
music
or if it was just like [ __ ]
painstaking sounds
uh that was great great stuff
and
yeah the
you know the the i i think the
cautionary tale of of this element
really rides more on how he should have
he shouldn't have done
this and he did like some messed up
things like i think that's pretty messed
up to move your family into a murder
house knowing god damn well it's a
murder house uh that's pretty messed up
and
and then and all the warning signs about
you should just go to the cops
or
you should just put this down generally
just wouldn't listen and and because you
kept
pursuing things that ultimately would
not bring him or his family
happiness
and and that's a good life lesson
there's also that
horror movie cautionary tale thing of uh
you know
don't
touch things that don't [ __ ] belong
to you
you know
that'd be thinking that way because when
i moved here there was some stuff left
behind and i was like ooh i kind of want
to just go through it you know
like male gets delivered here i'm like i
kind of want to open it
that juju could come from that you know
what i mean
um but yeah uh i i think that overall
this was a very effective horror movie
and it was ex it was exciting i was
thoroughly engaged and i started this at
like 12 45 at night or something like
that
and
i
[Music]
got the video right now but yet i feel i
was wide awake for it and had a really
good time and
it it it had more
nuance to it and some cool themes that i
just wasn't expecting i didn't know what
to expect out of it
but the package that i got i thought is
a really cool package
and this is one of the best ethan hawk
performances i've ever seen i've seen i
haven't seen like a ton of ethan hawk
movies and generally i think he's a
great actor
but this performance here i thought was
really great so yeah thank you guys for
being here this was a hell of a ride
and before i go i would like to end this
with a patron of the day shout out
tyler hague tyler the reason i'm
shouting you out is because
if i was stuck in just a terrifying
horror situation
where i couldn't leave a house
who would i want to be cozied up with
is you
we call you our cuddle bearer the
patreon
for a reason
so if i was in a horrific situation i
needed to feel safe
if i
just needed
to feel protected and to know
in here that everything's gonna be okay
i'd snuggle up with you you'd hold me
and keep me warm
and then if you had to
you just hold me into your belly
like in gladiator
and then just press my mouth into you
and then you put me out of my misery
which should be the ultimate relief
so tyler i love that you're willing to
kill me
if
tyler you're the man dude uh you're
absolutely right i should just say that
you're the best
and
and uh i miss hearing from you
but you've never left my mind and so
because
you're no g
and you're loyal as [ __ ]
and i'm so curious to know what you have
been up to lately actually i'm gonna
send you a message i'm so curious to
know what you've been up to it's been
it's been such a long time
playing any new video games
how's that book coming along does that
book come a long time
i'm delirious
see buddy
[Music]